yeah he's like wait a second maybe that was webcast but i need to look at the freaking
code because i need to have my proxy open valentino
best part of hacking when you can just you know critical thing right
so when you're running an enterprise security program there are quite a few things you need to
nail before you even consider doing something like running a bug bounty program right the
these are kind of like the abcs of enterprise security um obviously you need some sort of
phishing prevention system you need an edr you need some introspection into your environment with
logging and of course you need some sort of patch management system to make sure that your software
is constantly up to date and not gonna lie guys that last one is a little bit of a pain in the
butt right i know you guys know what i'm talking about with that it's it's a lot and whenever there
is something that's a pain in the butt in security what happens well threat locker always comes up with
an innovative solution and that's exactly what they've done with threat locker patch management
their team is working constantly to ensure the software updates for software in your ecosystem
are audited categorized so if there's like a super severe zero day you'll definitely know about it
and then check for conflicts with other software on your system before enabling the enterprise admin
to automatically update or schedule an update in the future and i'll just read this little snippet
from their website really quick which i loved it says we'll even dare to say install threat locker
patch management and forget about patch management we've got it covered that is what you love to hear
that is what you love to hear right okay so definitely check it out guys threatlocker.com
slash platform slash patch dash management or just go to threatlocker.com and and look for the patch
management software all right that's a wrap let's go back to the show all right we're rolling valentino my
man we've been wanting to do this episode ever since the live hacking event in google um thanks so much for
coming on the pod today yeah i am grateful for to be here so um yeah dude i'm looking at this doc with
the prep for that you've done for this episode and it is one of my favorite types of docs that i like to
see which is just absolutely stacked with hacking stories you know like like i often really like to
see you know people bringing on new research and i really like to see people bringing on fun bug stories
those two are the ones that i get really really hyped so we've got tons of really good bug stories in
here um so let's kick it off well okay typically i kick it off with a little bit of a um a little bit
of a bug story so let's see what we've got here we've got four different options take your pick man
which one do you want to talk about there are so many stories uh but i think i will start with the
first um so it is pretty simple i had a tomcat instance so with tomcat sometimes a system administrator
use a reverse proxy to expose it so basically it was exposed with a reverse proxy but
it had the default credentials so basically using the research uh published by orange dca which is called
a path normalization initials or something like that you can basically use dot dot a semicolon
and bypass but use a path to access the manager behind the response so so what was happening here so
that's that dot dot semicolon payload right is that the right one yeah yeah so that's like i freaking love
that research by orange side what a what a brilliant way to do it so i guess what was happening there was
you know you had a specific path that was allowed by the reverse proxy and and then you you know the
reverse proxy wasn't seeing dot dot semicolon as a as a path traversal yes and then you know the
backend server was and that's what allowed you to get access to that tomcat exactly just that and i love
it man there was another step which when you access with admin admin the tomcat manager you basically
weren't allowed to upload files it was restricted to localhost so that's where i found the jmx proxy sorry for
my pronunciation uh no you're good you're good jmx proxy okay so if you can't i upload the file uh being
logged in toncat because it was restricted to localhost you can basically use that proxy to jmx to exploit it
exploit that and get rc basically oh dude this is just check this out this is just uh straight up
like rc as a service here jmx this jmx proxy thing wow solid okay so if if you've ever if we ever run
into those scenarios where you can't hit you know the traditional tomcat manager instance like you
would and be able to upload a shell um because of their uh restrictions to localhost then you know we
we go in instead and hit this slash manager slash jmx proxy and then that one will allow us to execute
code either way yeah the only problem problem is that you need to have the role
uh call for to call that uh point but sometimes it is uh misconfirred so you can just call it
there you you need to have the role is that what you said yes sometimes people just keep all the roles
without thinking and yeah you can basically supply this classic classic i love it man that's a good
that's a good takeaway because i and i think i see these often man i i was very surprised i can't say
the name of the of the target but there was a target i was hacking on once that is literally like
a household name like i used this thing as a kid often like and on www dot you know that site.com there
was a path traversal just like this just dot dot semicolon slash and then it was dropping you right into some
work place where you could execute code so i think this these reverse proxy um you know setups that a
lot of people like to use uh if you can if you can detect them i think that there's a large um surface
attack surface there uh for some sort of scanner that we haven't really seen hit hit the scene you
know just yet of like okay here are the application segments you know at slash assets now we're looking
at an s3 bucket you know at slash app we're looking at this you know dot net backend you know whatever
we're looking at some static nginx assets or whatever right if we can identify these application
segments on a target then oftentimes there's a lot of weird vulnerabilities we can do with path
normalization yeah it is crazy orange does all that stuff and it is crazy you can get so many things
uh yeah yeah what is this what is this other write-up you linked here that was on wayback urls that
that uh that isn't up anymore some chinese write-up or something like this i was stuck
in this issue in that part that i told you i couldn't upload files and i found this chinese
blog and it's and i and i found that you could be cool exploit that uh that brought it that's that was
the key to uh that's where the jmx manager thing came from yeah nice man nice we'll link that down in
the description that's that's hilarious though uh oh yeah and they even list an exploit tomcat jmx rc exploit
um very cool yeah okay it's basically it's log poisoning basically oh really okay nice nice log
poisoning dude i think log poisoning is on everybody's radar now ever since the log4j thing where it's like
oh my gosh this has got to be all over the place um yes that's pretty sick yeah i definitely recently
i've been on an on something i've been working on i've been off of hacking uh almost since almost
since the google live hacking event i've just had a bunch of stuff come up i've been working with
a couple companies and just this past couple weeks i've been back hacking on bug bounty programs
again and uh like blind xss in logs or or like you're talking right here log poisoning with some
server-side logic um such a fun type of vulnerability uh it feels a little wish-washy to me though sometimes
because i'm like you know i'm trying all these random things i'm trying to guess what's happening
on the back end uh and i just hope something calls back you know yes i i love to to black box
the hugging is yes it's a totally different skill right i mean then then white box uh testing you
know there are a lot of really talented white box testers that i know but when you see a really
talented black box tester it's like they've got some like sixth sense of what's happening with the
application and and i think all of us have that to some degree right that have been successful in the
industry but there are some people that are just like yeah that is definitely how they coded it let
me just say i'm like what the heck yeah in the world event it seemed like that like yeah i i was just
oh yeah uh this might work and it worked but it does indeed indeed it didn't make sense then it took
like an entire week to find the cost it's like yeah yeah absolutely man all right well you you presented
your bug you you proved your your hackerhood to the listeners um i'll give you a quick intro and then
we'll hit some of these other bugs real quick um so as i mentioned guys this is valentino uh i met valentino at
the google live hacking event in tokyo or maybe it was the one before that yeah yeah yeah i think yeah
in vegas that's right it was in vegas that we met the first time but then in in tokyo we were kind of
neck and neck for the for the mvh there and uh sitting next to valentino at dinner you know we we
talked about a lot of bugs and and i was really impressed with his methodology so i've been wanting
i wanted to get him on the the the live talk at uh at the google event but we didn't get to do it
because of timelines being constricted but um we do have the opportunity to do that now so i'm i'm very
excited um let's go ahead and and jump through the rest of these valentino um and talk through some of
these well no no all right let me back out you've already proved your worth now let's go into a little
bit of history how did you how did you get into infosec and hacking and then we'll get into the rest of
the bugs that you popped okay so i got into infosec when i was around 12 years old i didn't even know
what i was doing today i kind of know a bit so in that time uh i was playing a lot of minecraft like
like 12 hours a day and my parents were telling me please you need to study stop playing that game
so one day i got bored of the game and i started to learn how to make servers
so my by building servers i noticed that uh let's say the servers are basically basically networks you
have multiple minigames and you have like a an authentication server where you log in then lobby
and then you can access whatever minigame you want so i noticed that the mapping proxy was just
specifying each minigame as a as a port so i i thought what if i just access the mini game directly
it's like a no-brainer and so i i did and it worked and that was my first issue
dude what what how hype must have you been at like 12 or 13 dude but like yes it worked you know
i was scanning entire pps providers like the entire blocks all night the asn ranges yeah my parents told
me what is this charge about the pps and i told them no no worries i am learning a server administration
there you go nice man i i also started hacking when i was like 12 and uh the sketchy stuff that we do at
that at that age to learn how to hack stuff man yeah it's it's great but it was such an exciting time
too you know like when you first pop something and something actually worked some exploit actually worked
it's like ah that's that's the best feeling yeah yeah i i think uh i think minecraft as well dude i think
minecraft has been a what a what a um a piece of software that just pushes people towards highly
technical roles right yeah like not only does the game you know have a lot of programming like
components with all the stuff you can do um with like the buttons and automation and stuff like that
but also you know this whole concept of hosting servers and you know running that business or running
that from a hacking perspective has just brought so many people into the technical route yeah it is
crazy i know many people that are gamers that were gamers and then hackers it's like really common yeah
yeah very common flow um very nice man so so you you got into it a little bit at 12. where does the
story pick up after that after that i might well there were some protections that were implemented
and i liked the idea of bypassing those predictions so i there was a protection that basically checked that
the original ip was localhost and well it was bypassable oh my gosh you can just by spoof the ip and that's it
yeah oh my gosh dude and then that's another set of uh of vulnerabilities on all of these minecraft targets
well it is similar to the course i think uh the original thing and uh yeah it is i i learned so many
things in in minecraft that i applied in web hacking it's like so nice yeah dude absolutely so how did you
make the jump from hacking minecraft stuff over to being a pen tester or bug bounty hunter so at that time
my parents basically restricted my assets to the computer yeah so classic i had to study in school for
two years uh and then uh when i was 16 when i was uh when i got better at the school i returned to
hacking but knowing knowing the stuff behind like i started learning programming
and then i learned java the basics of security and then i started with hack the bots
it is a lab for ctf and yeah that's the point where i learned a lot of stuff and i started hacking
with labs not with real world targets like yeah yeah i think i think you know likewise i when i was 12 13
14 15 a lot of the stuff i was hacking on was you know illegal illegal hacking stuff uh you know things
that i didn't have authorization to hack on um because i think at the time there wasn't labs as easily
accessible as well or at least i didn't know about them right um and so then you know once we get access to
the data that's going to be a problem i think it's going to be a problem i think it's going to be a problem
and i think it's going to be a problem i think it's going to be a problem i think it's going to be a problem
and then you can start like honing your skills and it's based off of real vulnerabilities and uh you
can do it in a lot more ethical way but i'm sure that there are a lot of kids out there even today
that are just like yeah i hadn't really put the thought into oh maybe there's a lab out there where
i can practice this rather than just popping shells on people's web servers randomly yeah that's that's
but yeah i the the problem is that kids might think it is fun but yeah it is fun but it is illegal so
don't do it exactly right exactly i'm looking at the rest of the notes here man and it looks like
you you did the oscp and then quote after getting that certification i received some job offers and the
day after my 18th birthday i started my first pen testing job dude that is a pretty sick record man
uh like starting your your first pen testing job the day after you turn 18. um well so you were getting
the oscp before you were 18 even uh i started the oscp when i was uh 17 because i the i i had to the
final year in my school but i choose to not do it i choose to do it at a to do from from home homeschooling
uh so homeschooling yeah i i just spent like two days a week for school and the entire week for
hacking so dude okay my man you were also homeschooled i i was homeschooled all of my my childhood like
and it was great because i whenever i was hacking something right or doing some programming job like
i was when i was younger i would often go up to my mom and be like hey mom so uh i got this like
programming job i'm going to do this for the next couple days and then i'll catch up on math or
english right or whatever right and she was like all right just don't you know way to go how do you
like i'm glad you're making money just make sure you don't get behind on school and then as long as i
got my school caught back up then we were good to go and i just i credit that with so much of my
success you know as a as a hacker and as a programmer just being able to have that flexibility and
entrepreneurial spirit at a young age and then being able to implement it without you know having to
be locked up at school all day yeah in those times you have so much free time that you can just
uh be quick with the school and and and and yeah exactly man exactly i love that that's that's amazing
that you're one of the only other people i've ever met that you know was homeschooled as well and
used that time to go to go hack stuff that's that's clutch man is that is that common at all in our in
argentina or is that um um no it is it is not common uh but there are some people that can do it uh
but yeah i i just did the last year but because i was tired of school it's like five hours a day
five days a week it was a lot like it was it is a lot yeah and and and shout out to your parents for
for allowing you to do that i mean i think that's that's pretty cool that they were open to that
sort of thing i know i know here in the us homeschooling is like skyrocketing like like
like the the amount i think it's grown 50 year over year for the past like five years like it's
just getting massive yeah um and and so i i really i was really glad to see that and sometimes it can
be done really really poorly and the people are not learning their stuff and they're getting socially
isolated but for me you know with with uh with parents that were actively involved and i still got
to play my sports and you know had community outside um as well as a you know very intentional
education at home uh it worked super well yeah it it depends uh on the parents and and yeah it can be
very well so yeah yeah yeah yeah um all right so we're 18 years old we have a pen testing job we're
18 years old in one day and we're starting a pen testing job um how do you get into bug bounty and how
how did you get invited to the bug swat event uh for for google uh it was really random like i i think
most things that happened with google were random for me at least i was thinking okay i saw a tweet
that i asked do you want to hack ai in a private event and i say said okay i i i sent the form and i thought
yeah they're not going to call me uh that there are more qualified people than me so yeah i i i waited
and i got the email and i said what so i i started learning how to hack ai and in the first event it was
really hard uh and another thing is that they just told me do you want to go to vegas and i and i said
uh i can't go i can't go to vegas because i i can't pay for the flight and the hotel it is expensive yeah
so they told me what if you if we pay for it and i said definitely yes of course yeah and i and i went
dude that's crazy man like so at that point had you submitted a lot of bugs to google or
uh i think um i i sent like two bags that weren't that great and and i i i registered to to the google
um to the google account in in the same month i did the the hacking event and but i didn't particularly
send uh high impact bucks and i got the invitation um in that moment i thought why i got this invitation
but yeah i i knew i had to to put my efforts yeah yeah this is what i'm saying man everybody's still
early on google right like this when was this valentino this was last vegas right this is vegas
2024 and this was in 2023 2023 okay gotcha 2023 vegas was when uh you first went with the google with
the google program yes nice okay yeah so guys it's still early with google man i mean just a couple
of years ago not even not even two years ago one year ago and some change valentino is like submitting
a form submitting two you know crappy bugs and then getting an invite to vegas so um it's it's an
amazing opportunity definitely spend some time on google it but valentino man it is kind of scary
right i mean hacking on google they they have a lot of obfuscation there's a lot of proto json right
um there's a lot of uh you know very minified products and and so what are your what are your
what are your tips and tricks on on hacking on google for the listener that wants to take up that
opportunity for me it is getting really used with one product product if you can talk with the security
team because they know a lot of stuff and basically the thing that worked for me is stopping stop looking
at the code stop look looking at the requests close the proxy like valentino my guy this is crazy advice
but it it worked for you right i've seen i've seen it work for you because there are so many things that
happen in in this application that you need some time to think what is happening in the back end was it
what is what is the application loading how you can what you need to think like the developer it's like
poker i think you need to get in the head of the people that made application and then you need to
look i i look for patterns i i try things that are weird and breaking stuff and then i see
uh what happened and how it happened all the all the bugs i found during the event i didn't use the
process i i dude that is just absolutely nuts and it's crazy to me because you know when we were
sitting at that dinner right that awesome dinner in in tokyo and we were chatting about the bugs that
you found i was listening to this and i was like ah yeah duh why did i like all of the attack pictures
that you came up with were so like simple but creative yeah and like showed a depthful understanding
of the product right and where the security boundaries are and i'm really like i'm glad to
have you on the pod dude because i think there are a lot of different types of hackers out there right
there are people that are just obscenely technical and will just like you know and and looking at
some of the stuff in here you got a little bit of both for sure right uh but you know there are some
people that are just they all they do is focus on like the the white box parts the code where they can
the part where they can get their hands on the code they read it they fully understand it they bend
it right and and then there's there's people that are that are just um unbelievably creative with
their attack vectors right and and i there's such a beauty to that ladder piece right and the the the
first is i think more of a science the ladder is more of an art right where it's like you know crafting
these these really um creative uh attack scenarios um and and to be honest for the listener uh i think
you should be encouraged because for for the creative piece there are a couple hackers that i know that
are are not very very technical i'm thinking of one friend that i have that has earned you know multiple
five-figure bounties just from being a insanely creative hacker uh and just using the ui right no no no
proxy no dev tools no nothing just clickety clickety clickety click so it definitely is possible right
yeah and it is crazy uh i i i couldn't find issues using the broad sea and all the things and then i
closed the broad sea and it i started finding a lot of uh bugs that were crazy it's i i started thinking i
i think it is a critical thing i i would add another thing which is a abstract thinking is really important
the problem is there are hackers that um well it's just not a problem it is
uh something but uh the thing is that there are hackers that need to know all the details like the code
everything but uh sometimes you need to really um understand that you will lack information and you
need to be comfortable with lacking information and guessing a bit dang dude that's deep that that hits
me right in the heart man i'm one of those guys that needs to see all of the pieces right i'm not i'm
not very good at not having you know some of those pieces and and for me you know when i'm hacking on
stuff i really i do try to line all those pieces up in my brain like like uh you know i'll i'll write
it down i'll map it out i'll draw it i've got these big yellow notepads that i have around that i just
sketch and like draw and and try to get it you know all in one piece but i need to be more comfortable
with the abstract right with with the with the uncertain pieces um and and just kind of take guesses
at what's happening or or educated you know guesses at what could be happening that's that's pretty right
it is hard it is hard for me it is hard to to do the thing you like having knowing the entire
application deeply it is hard for me because i i get distracted a lot but but i kind of feel it is
easier to just have some some information and just the make an inference like a inference with a abstract
thinking and it sometimes work it works yeah yeah absolutely man all right let's let's take a look
at a couple examples of that um you know one of the ones that was interesting that kind of that kind of
um highlights i think that that abstract thinking was your uh vulnerability that was just closed at
mercadolibre uh with with the html sanitizer can you talk a little bit about that but that's a disclosed report so we'll put it in the description for anybody who wants to follow along but
uh can you talk a little bit about what you found there yeah that was my first crazy bug like
it was my first the first time i i i thought in abstract uh terms uh i basically um
i saw a request that is basically in mercadolibre you can sell and buy products so i i tried making
a buying a product and then making a claim and then i saw the request uh with the claim and html
call and i said what is happening here it's like why it is sending html call so so this when you say a claim is
this like when you've bought something and you need to like get some support or something like that from
the seller or yes exactly uh basically you're uh trying to make a a claim to to return to proud uh or to
say something is wrong basically okay okay so you've got a support complaint and and you're and you're trying
to get support for the product maybe even return it and and when you do that the message that you send
contains html in it exactly yes dude don't you love to see that though don't like i my heart like skips
a little beat like whenever i see uh those you know encoded html tags inside of inside of my request i'm
like yes i know that there's going to be something interesting here yeah it is like awesome but it was
there was a sanitizer and that's a test sanitizer was a custom i think so i was able to make some guesses
and bypass it it's like and that bypass was crazy because um basically uh it had like a low list of
tags and when i not when i sent a multiple p tags uh it was maybe it's hard to see like the picture but
there were many open tags that you can if you send multiple open tags and then a malicious payload
it basically bypasses the filter for some reason dude it's crazy man i i it's crazy how some of this
stuff happens right like so you just have open p tab open p tab open p tag open p tag open p tag and
then like your xss payload and the thing just starts reading the p tags it's like all right yep it's another
pizza all right whatever it's fine you know just let it through and then it just opens up that's nuts
man nesting stuff nesting stuff is is really important when uh attacking a sanitizer yeah it is
it's it it is it it is uh i saw it is really important uh with uh the logs made by miso
exactly yeah yeah they they there's some there have been so many um dom dom purify bypasses because
of the depth restraints and uh essentially having namestays confusions because of the the sort of stack
reaching maximum depth and then um you know tags being normalized to the same you know spot within the
the nesting so it's pretty amazing yeah it is like and and the the more the most uh like crazy thing
is that in that time i didn't even look at the code so i i i don't know the root cause
i don't know valentino that would drive me crazy that would drive me like i cannot believe that you
didn't go back and read the freaking sanitizer code afterwards man like i mean unless it's happening on
the server side and you can't but you're just like p-tech p-tech p-tech p-tech oh it worked let's go
submit the report i'm like dude uh yeah it was crazy and and then they they put uh don't purify so yeah
oh geez yeah i think bummer man bummer well i i see you've got um a section of this doc where you say
that there are you know some patterns that are kind of sort of follow this uh this this structure
um in other pieces of hacking can you talk a little bit about that uh yes sure uh there were
uh uh do you mean the part uh the patterns and the perfection yeah exactly exactly yeah oh yeah uh so
in this uh vulnerability i i reflected on it and i think um there are some things that we can take
uh here uh there were there was a analog list uh so you you call basically wrap a malicious object inside
the uh an analog object and that bypasses the mitigations it is really interesting because it is
similar to insecure civilizations where you have an allow allow list and then you can just wrap a evil
objects inside and it works yeah yeah i think it's really important that we reflect upon those sort of
uh principles within hacking that makes us much better hackers is when we see this higher level pattern
right and what you what you're pointing out here is that sometimes there are allow lists right and the
inside of those allow lists you know there can be sub objects right that that should not be allowed
and and the the thing that's assessing it may only go you know one layer deep right so there's this
nesting part there's this allow list part we see this in in saml bypasses we see this in uh you know
deserialization we see this in in sanitizing bugs right html sanitizing bugs um definitely a common
pattern pattern that hackers need to be familiar with and apply to different areas of of hacking yeah it
is it is it is really cool how you can apply one thing can take one technique for from i don't know a
blockchain or like crypto crypto hacking and apply it somewhere else i one day i did this an experiment i
i read a blog uh a blog talking about a crypto bug i didn't understand almost anything but i read catch cash
many times and i thought this issue is is universal like grace conditions some of the scapes it's like
injection bugs they are like patterns in in software like
all over the place all over the place man yeah especially crypto because it's such a a unique area
you know with re-entrancy attacks and stuff like that you know trying to take those principles and
apply them to other areas and and to take you know the areas of traditional web security and apply them
uh to other things right we see this stuff happening with uh with
uh ai related vulnerabilities and and every new area that pops up there's the same old problems that we
have from before just taking a different form um all right man now now we've we've kind of gone through
a couple of these let's let's hit the the onslaught of really crazy bugs that you have um in here and
hear a bunch of stories so um i'm looking right now at the command injection in vertex ai one of the google
products and this one i read your little write-up on here beforehand so cool dude so tell the listeners
about that i think they're really going to enjoy it and and um can i share this doc this related draft
document or um yes yeah okay cool i'll uh i'll share it and maybe it'll help the users visualize a little
bit uh the command injection in vertice ai uh it was a another crazy bug i found without looking at the
valentino stop man what do you did please don't do this to me oh my gosh okay what do you tell me about
it it is really fun because it was basically in vertice ai you have like a a feature where you can
text prompts with different models so i noticed you can embed a content and then you can use a feature
called get code which generates code to call the the apis with your test prompt so i thought what if i just
can use a code quote and escape the the and reform command injection it didn't work but then i thought
well images are interesting uh have been interesting uh with google so i just put an image and and escape
uh in in a match url and then i got the command injection there okay okay whoa whoa whoa whoa valentino
hold on you can't just say and then i got the command injection so okay so what's going on here is
this file that's that's being uploaded if i'm understanding this right up correctly this file
that's being uploaded is is a json file right that represents what a prompt oh sorry yeah yeah yeah
yes i i skipped a part uh no you're good you're good tell me about it so basically the problem is that
the the command injection needed the user to copy and paste the content in the chat so it was too much
much interaction so i decided to find an indirect way of introducing that malicious content so i i found
another feature called a prompt management that's where you can import a prompt with with a json file
with some variables and data and yeah the attack is basically the user downloads a prompt file imports it
and then after using the get code it inserts the command escaping the url url which is inserted in that code
that's okay okay okay okay hold up hold up a second so uh so you're you're taking a json attacker prepares
a you know yes prompt uh template or whatever json file and then they upload that to vertex ai right yes
and now the the prompt that you've prepared is in their vertex ai and then you said they hit the get code
button what does the get code button do the the the get code basically uh generates a code to call a the the
google ai apis uh to test the prompt
ah okay okay so then this allows this gives you some way to um use this specific prompt that you've
prepared via the google apis yes yes ah okay and then when you do that it it generates some some code either
some is it is it bash python what did you say it was in the scenario uh you have uh many options like a
cool bash uh well bash is cool uh then python and node shares etc so wow and then and and so what
was happening there was you know it would generate it and it would somehow pass in this prompt you know
to to the the i guess curl let's just say curl in this scenario in this curl request right so maybe
it's using like you know binary data or just like dash d or whatever in curl right yes and then and then
inside of that json you were able to provide something that would break out of the json object within
the the so it's like a command line argument injection yeah it was like a just common exception without anything
tricks like just uh the end and the end of line okay and you need to close the multi-line
thing and then you can just insert it it wasn't like complicated at all nice nice so um i've seen
this kind of bug several times and it was really cool because the first time i saw it it was done by
um int i don't know if you know the hacker int he's kind of og in the in the bug bounty space he did the
ticket trick um uh research back in the day and we were at a live hacking event and he he got show
and tell he was like one of the best bugs of the event because he said um rce via content injection
and because he was able to generate like like you did here you know inject into a code block that
was supposed to be copied and pasted into you know somebody's code you know into their .php file at the
time right and he was able to just specify arbitrary um arbitrary php within that and and then it would
run on the victim server and i think that this is a uh pretty niche niche bug right it's not it's it's uh
something that you see pretty often but not a lot of people try as content injection inside of these
um very multi-contextual environments right where there's lots of context there's the curl context
there's the json context there's the hdp context it's very very cool attack vector yeah basically because
i mean it requires some injection but still the origin is trusted so you need to be careful yeah yeah
absolutely um all right let's let's see all right vertex ai that one was pretty cool google gave
you a good a good bounty for that let's come back to some of these other stories that you have up at the
top um you mentioned deserialization earlier it looks like you've done some work with dot net and java
deserialization do you want to talk about one of those too um i i i won't say i i know much about
deserialization because i found i found the bug and i read the paper the entire paper and that that was it
like i i i i did some research like two weeks uh just to exploit the bug and and then i i i forgot about it
like yeah what what paper were you reading at the time for deserialization that you used to exploit this
i read many papers written by alvaro munoz which are so great to start with a deserialization and then i
read this massive paper by piotr passillo which is awesome like it i i i i feared deserializations
way way back but that paper made me realize it is very fun and interesting to play
yeah dude this guy piotr oh my gosh this is chuddy pd yeah dude he's he's unbelievable man i've i've uh
i've read some we've covered some of his stuff on the pod before i'd love to have him on the pod
um the stuff that he comes out with uh specifically surrounding the pontone research that he does
is like unbelievable um very crazy stuff um all right all right what's this all right jump
it on the list what is this argument injection to lfr in parsing component oh there there was a time
i have um it was a this was a white was a kind of uh hacking so when i look at the code it seemed
safe but i found a way to shed an argument and then it it called a specific parsing tool
so i needed to basically read the manual and and and see which arguments i can use to get some impact
so i i i reverse engineered the binary a bit and then i found a way to trigger a server-side request
for sharing with a local file read and leak files oh my gosh so so it was a it was a um argument injection
someone is this is in a web app i presume uh yes yes okay so it's an argument injection from a web
app web app is calling some sort of command line utility that command line utility you go and reverse
find you know you've got an argument injection in there so you add an argument that takes a file from
the user's local machine and somehow yeets it out to some you know throws it to some attacker controlled
server is that right yeah like to be more specific basically it prepares a request and it reads a file
that this is supposed to be a header with some credentials or some data so it sends that header in the request
that that is supposed to go to a server legitimate server but you can just put the etc password in the
header value and and it works yeah you check your server's logs that it's like you know authorization bearer
root you know it just jumps the whole etsy password file yeah dude i love that man uh hacky stuff like
that where it's like you get these malformed http requests and somehow your server catches it it's like
oh my gosh i love this it is that's that's beautiful man that's really beautiful um all right dude uh
uh i i i'm i'm going down here i'm looking at some of the other stuff you've got i really liked this um
this thing that you um called uh free after use right not use after free but free after use i thought
that was really funny can you tell us about that specific vulnerability what happened there and how
um the listeners can look for a similar vulnerability yeah uh basically there uh i was looking for
authorization issues like eye door and all that but it was tricky to find eye doors because they are so
common that are fixed very quickly so i thought uh why what if i just access basically the concept free after
use is looking for moments where the application does some weird stuff when a use a specific user accesses
uh a specific resource in this case i know an owner of a resource access his metrics for instance and then
uh i could basically um when when the owner accesses the metrics everyone can access the metrics it's like
uh when they that that's why i called it a a what's called a free after use they use the user the owner
uses the the the the component and it is free like then it becomes free for everyone that's hilarious
man so i i think i think this is a pretty niche scenario i i have seen it before for sure where
you know some routes will just be for some reason um like presented like that it's an authorization issue
um but one of the other places where you often see this is caching related vulnerabilities right like
if there is a server at some point somewhere that is caching whatever resource and then serving it you
know and another person hits that resource um once it's already in the cache then it's not hitting any of
the back-end logic it's just presenting that same data again to the other user um so very similar to
webcash deception in that way yeah it is really similar to that yeah and i know that i think it yeah
yeah he's like wait a second maybe that was web cache but i need to look at the freaking code because
i need to have my proxy open valentino oh my god dude um yeah yeah that's definitely a good one yeah when
i for instance uh relating to the sanitizer bypass uh earlier when i read uh the don't purify misconfiguration
side bypasses uh block by miso i thought oh this is pretty similar to what i did uh yeah this is uh this is
the bug so so i'm wondering valentino i i know you know how old are you right now do you mind sharing
on the pod or no uh what the thing sorry i how how old are you oh uh now 21 21. okay so you're a younger
guy right you're a younger guy in this scene you've been doing this for for for three years um i think
you've had a lot of success here clearly finding a lot of vulnerabilities um do you think that your
evolution you know your growth as a hacker will come with understanding some of these things at a more
technically depthful level or are you going to try to spend time trying to foster and grow in yourself
that creative and abstract thinking which way do you see yourself going as a hacker and maybe it's both
but i'm just curious uh i think uh there is a limit to creativity so i think and and there is lack
in that creativity so i i think i'm going to go to the more technical route and to really understand
the deeper parts so yeah i think that's a good idea i i think that's a good progression and i think
you're you're right that there is luck and there is limits to creativity um kind of crazy though that
you play second at the google live hacking event off of that so uh i think maybe you're like your
creativity levels are like super high from a um you know from a baseline perspective um and and let me
ask you this you know you you sort of um mentioned uh several times throughout this this pod that you
think that a lot of this has to do with spending a lot of time on an application right on the pod we call
you're getting intimate with the application you know you know you know everything about this application
you can you know hold it in your hands you're like i know exactly what you are um so yeah i think you
know that do you find that that creativity gets spurred more after you feel like you've understood
all the parts of the application um or do you think it's more uh in as a part of that process of
understanding everything about the application i think uh basically playing around with an application
for a lot of time like i i have been sending bugs like to a single application for at least two years
all right guys listen to what valentino says here say it again for the people in the back
valentino say it again i have been finding bugs in a single application for two years but two years
two years guys listen to what valentino is saying you so many people valentino so many
people valentino will say to me i've been hacking on this app for so long i can't figure it out can't
get any bugs i'm like how long have you been hacking they're like two days and i'm like dude like like
you haven't spent any time on this i'm still reading the docs two days and you know sometimes so i
think it's really key what you mentioned here yeah and sometimes you need to spend like eight hours a
day in a single application every every day like uh in in the first year i i spent like i just look at
at the application like uh four hours then uh the next month uh 12 hours and like keep revisiting the
application keep going back and check new things new new thoughts uh i found in those two years i found
most of the bugs in three months like i started popping the bugs when i really understood the
application like like a user like someone that just tries the application like uses the application
yeah yeah absolutely man that that is super pivotal and i wonder valentino do you you know you
mentioned you said earlier that sometimes you get bored quickly um do you like but you're you're spending
a lot of times on these applications do you think that you're like do you have to force yourself to
refocus on some of these apps do you get bored with them and then but force yourself to come back to them
uh sometimes i get extremely interested in in an application that i i sometimes i have a different
problem which is i want to focus on google cloud and i can't because i i i keep going back to the same
application it's like a fixation uh like i i know there are there are more bugs but sometimes i
for instance with google cloud which is a target i i really i am really starting to like i really want to
crack there but i get like distracted all the time like it's like is it do you get distracted by new
applications or by older applications or by both i get distracted by everything like i start reading the
docs of births.ai and i start thinking how what are the differences between you know the that there are
different servers in different regressions and what are the difference says between the languages
or the encodings in different servers and i like i think like crazy things that
probably won't work like do you know the orange dca for instance uh polish a blog where he told the what
dca i don't i don't think i know it no he published a blog about encodings and with sql
uh ah the is it though is this the defcon talk on like injecting uh like at the binary protocol for sql
oh no no it it it it was a ctf challenge uh okay i don't think i've seen it like i i one day i i
have decided to read all the ctf challenges made by the biology because he's a really cool researcher
and one write-up was that a name with a specific encoding is converted to a an ascii a
and you can basically bypass the admin check or things like that and i thought that might work in
google cloud but if if i start thinking about many things and i can't focus on a single thing right
now it's like yeah that's yeah that's that is one of the problems with some of these big targets
right like google cloud or aws and stuff there's so many ideas kind of bouncing around and and sometimes
they're a little technically difficult to implement and so i find myself sitting and scheming and
writing down and stuff like that and then i realize yeah dude but the only way i'm actually going to
find vulnerabilities is if i try stuff if i actually like go and technically implement it right yeah so
i got to pause for a second and then make sure i'm i'm keeping my throughput of of like things that
i've tried i gotta keep that high so that i can keep my volume output high and google is so massive and so
like like if the at first it i was scared of hacking google same that's if you feel like comfortable
hacking google then you start finding stuff it's like yeah yeah yeah it is a scary target but it's
definitely doable man definitely doable um let's jump to this section uh i love this section even titled
issues in file extension validation components um because you've got two pretty solid checks that i
always check for as well here uh and they they really do help help often so talk about these two um two
tips you have for the listeners on bypassing uh file extension validation checks so basically
whenever you have a file extension validator you can try stuff like the null byte uh etc but in in my case i i i
found a component that basically in the backend somewhere hidden was a crafting an url and you can basically you could
basically um do that html uh how is that called like the hashtag the hashtag and the that png basically the png was
a load and the html was disabled so basically the uri parser ignores the rest of the hashtag so you can
basically bypass the filter that way and yeah dude i love both this one and the question mark right
because it it takes it it takes advantage of the differences between which characters are special characters
in a file context versus in a actual http context right you know a hashtag is a perfectly valid character
in in a file name but in the http context that is the beginning of the the hash fragment right which
truncates the rest of the of the request um so very solid i love to see that that's that's great yeah it
it is amazing like the last research made by orange dca with a question mark as well like yeah it is amazing
absolutely um you got another one here what is this one uppercase yeah the next one is like a simpler
because it was just xml with an uppercase that was it like basically some validators
uh have a whitelist or blacklist which that only checks uh lowercase characters and it doesn't shake
like uh it isn't case insensitive basically
uh dude i will never forget to check this because of one freaking live hacking event and you guys have
heard me talk about it on the pod before listeners so it's this live hacking event with freaking matias
carlton uh he had a crit that all on on a piece of um scope that all of us had seen and he bypassed
like a reverse proxy because of one capital letter we were all like man if we could only get access to
his admin panel you could only get access to his admin panel and he'd just take one of the letters
the last letter and he converted it to uppercase and it let him in and i was like i will never forget
to do this ever again um so that i think that's one of the beauties of the live hacking event right
valentino where it's like you know you see all the things that other people have tried and you know
how hard you are banging your head up against the same scope trying trying trying and the way you see
other people solve it and it's so like infuriating that you didn't solve that that you never ever
forget in your life you know to do that attack vector ever again yeah sometimes that i i i look at
at the hat like at the show and tell i think oh my god i i this is like something i i will never think
like so creative and so like but simple at the same time like yeah yeah yeah there's there's both
extremes they're like wow yeah i was never even close to that but the ones that stick with me the
most are the ones that are like oh that was right in front of me i'm such an idiot how did i not try
that yeah that is painful yeah it's painful man yeah all right um i'm gonna jump down to this last one
and then we're gonna call it a wrap for the day um this was a write-up on your blog um and just kind
of have a couple sql uh injection vulnerabilities right um this is pmb uh and one of the ones that i kind
of wanted to point out here is that you had an authenticated c-surf to sqli within this um write
up right which i think is just a really good uh thing for your for the the listeners to understand
because a lot of people would think okay sqli like why would i need to c-surf that well you know from an
from an unauthenticated perspective sometimes you can't even access these endpoints but if you if you are
able to do a cross-site request forgery and trigger an sql injection in the back end your c-surf can
result in something massive like a server-side vulnerability right like sqli or oftentimes you
see rce as well um so yeah dude it was great to see that right up here and did you how did you learn
about that technique was that you just kind of um coming you know out of your head there or did you
see somebody who who had implemented this before um i basically had the sql injection and i thought
uh yeah this is like uh really not great uh because you needed uh like credentials uh so i thought
well it is just a get request so i can see a use a cross-site request for g and i did like it was
like uh like intuitive like uh just yeah yeah and and i've actually had a a good amount of success
with these actually working you know in a bug bounty environment um because a lot of times people will be
like uh you know admins he serves it's kind of hard to prove but specifically within a um uh and not
not in this scenario you know this is a different scenario but specifically within a wordpress environment
where you can create you know you can install the same plugin and if there's like a c-surf to rce
or c-surf to sqli in that plugin then um you know you can prove to the triagers hey this works
on an admin for sure and uh and has large impact like in sql in rce um so i i think that's a really
good uh takeaway in these environments yeah it is uh it is a really good yeah nice man um i i did
forget about this this ai hacking section down here at the bottom did you have any comments uh i've got
to wrap up here in about uh 10 minutes but did you have any any um tips you wanted to give the listeners
on the ai hacking experiences you've had with google or or outside of google over the past uh years too
yeah basically what i would say is uh please always take into into always think models are super
inconsistent so try many variations try opening new charts try uh if you if you trigger the bat
don't don't don't get uh scared if it doesn't work in another chat you didn't lose the bat they didn't
fix it just a a a a a thing i i learned is that you can just copy the entire set of instructions paste
it in another chat and it sometimes work with a few tweaks uh and yeah that's like the most important
thing i learned um and and also take um into consideration that some programs don't need the full
chain you can just report the data situation but i i would say it is important to show you can leak sensitive
data and not just regular data and basically another thing i will say is martown is just the beginning
yes agreed man agreed all right great tips let's cut it there leave that for the listeners to go thanks
for coming on the pod man i appreciate it yeah thank you and that's a wrap on this episode of
critical thinking thanks so much for watching to the end y'all if you want more critical thinking
content uh or if you want to support the show head over to ctbb.show discord you can hop in the
community there's lots of great high level hacking discussion happening there on top of master classes
hack alongs exclusive content and a full-time hunters guild if you're a full-time hunter it's a great
time trust me i'll see you there